so in this Dr my hands don't go in and
out I hands stay where they are stay
where
they does that is that
visible
now now and stay
how far can my front knee
go to the yog line which is to the
toes so I can't
go past
it the back foot the back knees on the
young line then the front on the young
one
boom okay try it
okay do not
emphasize him like you're right now do
not do that so if I'm doing the solo
training then the Y energy is going into
me and I'm dropping it I now amplify the
Y energy with him okay so I bring that
onto the back F when I go forward the
young energy will amplify again so
instead of being back on the surface
with his
hands I keep entering that young
energy into
me so as I'm doing this then I shouldn't
have to move because that has nothing to
do just there's no movement in this solo
drills it's not movement related mov
is just trying
to make the energy more gross for the
less sensitive that's all it's trying to
do but you don't want to change the
mechanism of what you're
doing so
thereby I shouldn't have to move my arms
in and out but nor should I
tense I am very
relaxed I move here I'm very
relaxed and I'm very relaxed
okay so you're going to
feel once you try to come back that's a
lot of energy don't start tensing
against it you just did the anti-
trining in release
Down
release through and
out release
Down release through and out okay try it
[Music]
okay all right on this one let's say
well I'm going to get a bicep tie here
so he's grabbing at me going to get the
bicep tie and I get to add that thir
control point of my
head okay so if let's say he we're we're
now in close range grappling cuz I
passed the elbow you see okay so let's
say he wants to try uh a leg attack of
any kind go ahead so you can't control
hands you see with these three things
okay
um I can come around the outside you see
and get pull and then he'll do the
counter fear reaction he goes back and
now it opens up your leg attacks okay so
however you get there find the inside
line get the control Point here if he's
driving at you you're just
grounding
okay you're not just kind of laying here
or
bracing so I'm he's going to push then
you're just grounding on the it's on the
back foot
okay
again he'll push on you and we're do the
grounding drill on the back
foot it'll push on you and you ground
that okay and again my arms are very
relaxed right he's driving but it's on
the back foot
okay okay so a rule on any tie whether
you're in this this tie here is your
head has to be on the same vertical
plane as your foot you can't be out here
don't kill me you got jerk me down
okay so when you do coming in and you do
the tie you have to keep that foot in
that same vertical
plane you're not like this
bracing you're in here grounding on the
back foot okay got it so he pushes and
you're just on the back foot this is
very relaxed but it's helping me be on
the inside of okay that foot is
underneath my head not back okay clean
it
up my head is
here not here underneath underneath his
head
in the crook of his neck so I his body
is wrapping around my head I want it fit
fitted okay so to test your head
placement we're going to have him uh
drop for that leg attach you see how I
can use that to can you go forward you
see just with the head
alone okay so we'll add this and we'll
test on the head you're still grounding
on the foot
coming in boom I'm in position foot's
underneath my head okay he drive cool
we're not going anywhere so drrive you
come off very quickly and I'm not going
forward okay just just like here he let
he I'm if I'm bracing and he lets go
you're going to go forward okay so here
you're grounding he's driving you're
grounding he lets go quickly and and you
shouldn't move at all okay he'll come
back in boom he'll try to lower go ahead
and you'll just stay with he'll drive
again okay he'll come off quickly and
you won't fall again so little spot test
for those things go okay uh I don't know
do if he's doing a strike okay so I I'm
going to stick to that strike right if
he starts to retract it I'll stick to it
okay I'm not going to go over here and
I'm like trying to do this stuff or
likewise when I'm here I'm going to
stick to his body so I have equal y on
the on the head you see okay so when he
drops I can drop with him it's not that
I'm trying to see him drop and then you
try to
go you keep the the young value equal
when he drops it's easy peasy okay about
it so that up it's not different you're
just using your head not the
hand okay do you comes in it get it good
get it get it okay I drive boom I'm off
and I drop okay he's with me I drive I'm
off okay and from here I'm going to test
that foot scoot it back a little and
then you're going to get that okay got
it try it for
you have too much bracing angle and your
head's over your
foot it's in front of her
foot go put your head back where it was
okay put it in front of your foot
there's the whole head in front of your
foot push down
Maya okay you're not helping her by that
okay same thing comes
in we we'll just do where he drops down
okay as he drops down and now he's going
to go for the near leg cuz that's only
thing that makes sense okay so when he
goes for the near leg that's when I pass
that arm over this thing
okay and that's
sh do it again boom he drops I stay with
him you'll feel this hand he's going to
try to grab that leg so grab the leg you
see you're controlling it I don't know
where you are camera but you want to be
on this side so I go from the bicep tie
and I slide down to you see I'm on your
forearm right Ron in that upper forearm
in your elbow so now that arm doesn't
Bend if I'm here it's going to bend and
you're going to get it you can get it
you think you get it so when I feel him
go for the leg come off my body I slide
down I'm on the inner arm now you see
that hinge doesn't work but instead of
fighting it as he goes for it that's
when I pass it
okay do it
again he drops I stay with him you'll
feel him open and pass it okay shifting
your
weight okay let's try it
[Music]
don't pick them up throw them
down for
[Music]
so come in you get bicep tie drop right
away that's what I want to see drop
right away for the ankle Pig
[Music]
got to pass it got to stay sensitive on
the arm
[Music]
got to pass
it all right so he's coming in I get it
he drops right I here it depends what he
does okay so he's in his Turtle right so
I'll find my hooks juicy get my hooks
come in and secure it okay start working
back
M comes in boom he BR if he goes flat
flat then your strikes okay boom
stri I don't know how but some of you
are like turning over you see and this
is top now and see if you can get that
arm cross face you see how I got it so
now you can work your gift wrap you have
your Goku at the bottom
okay so follow up with something goes
flat it
Stomps
um he Turtles his back Mount he goes on
his side his top mount okay if he goes
uh flat or top mount and you lost
connection cuz he went really really far
then it's going to be your your kicks
your roundhouse kicks and things like
that okay don't don't jump on a guy that
you already lost uh
connection good
w
[Music]
come
Center get centered use a seat Bel to
Center
[Music]
yourself your weight has to go on him
so the inside foot has to go
first hey watch Sean get on this side
please okay so he's going he goes to the
turtle your first step this leg goes
here don't leave it
here this first step goes here and my
weight goes on him so my feet can move
okay seat belt once you secure meaning
you're not too high and you're not off
to the side so I use all this to decide
where I want to go so he kind of sat
back on me do you see that he's sitting
back on his butt go back up so he's
sitting back up once I'm here I'll work
the Superman's okay go back I'll show it
okay he goes forward on me I work the
Superman okay go back
up he sits back on me then I work the
rolls we go this
way but first secure that first hook on
the homolateral side your weight goes on
him so your feet are free to move if
you're keeping your weight off him you
can't move your feet he doesn't feel
anything get the seat belt first figure
out what he's going to do and then
that'll give you your opening
okay okay so he B he bicep TI
right and you feel you feel these three
points of contact right got got it okay
and uh I can't go towards him so I use
these
adhesions to move
him okay so you'll feel when he goes
pull and I move him slightly so I'm
going to I'm going to open it up so you
can see he's got his hands on the biceps
and that's your con con Point that's
what you move okay he's got his head
right here that's your connection Point
that's what you
mooved he's coming in that's my y that
was the Yong he did when he came in
right when he's pushing on me if I
didn't stay still here he'd push me
back so I ground it Bo I mooved there's
the arm the arm gra right there okay and
I'm
in I go tackle he goes here I move it
there it is right
[Music]
there I I start your counter I mooved it
there it is right
there it's very hard if I'm here and he
has the bicep
TI I can't get there I can't get there
to that arm you'll check it you see open
H up so what I do here is I move the
other arm to me not here move there it
is right there Then P I'm break it down
to there I go here pull there it is
Boom okay try some of you are doing
external I'm going to grab right and
then I you moved you you see you moved
you to it but he's not going to let you
move he's going to move with you right
he's got all those points of connection
I go to move I'm not going to get there
do you understand so it happens when he
goes
there instantly at that long moment you
guys understand okay so we're going to
dial it back cuz you're just arm
dragging it's not going to be there he
has so much control with this position
okay you you move and he moves with you
you're not going to get it defend
yourself on trying to get that arm it's
not going to
happen so we'll just start
here just like training he'll drive into
you and you project that
off since we're more in application base
I'm not going to project it back into
him I'm going to start the fight
rotating so he comes in no different
than this he comes
in he comes in ohom project
off in Project off okay now now what I
want you to do is to go
seamless not not in two moves
one
two
seamless right when he drives to get
that head he's going to drive to get
that head that's my young energy boom
seamless okay
after
that be wary so like for
example if if he's really driving
right uh of course I can move him the
four feet but he's going to he's going
to fight that right he's going to do
things you see so he curved around the
arm and he let go go back he let go of
that cuz that was a projection point now
he didn't have move move okay that's
what they're going to do if you're
reading the good taichi article that's
what I told you they're going to do it's
just forced to them he he doesn't care
how many decades it took to get what
metaphysical means it got there here it
just something's pushing on my arm let
taking my position and my balance okay
so don't
expect big things so all I'm doing here
is taking this arm
from the Yang
line and projecting it to the Jong ding
line and now the other hand can be
utilized okay release through non-
contestation
pull I'm going to go seamless but slowly
okay I go in he goes
boom boom
okay try
it notice that when he I went here I
projected onto the curve on the spir
will
rotate
okay I tried as I showed you last time
if I try to project him straight he's
not going to do
that the what he feels displacing his
posture which is his line of
gravity is within his base of support
whatever he feels is causing that line
of gravity to go outside of the base of
support he will adapt to okay so since
he's touching me here and he's touching
me here that's what he is going to
counter so you see he went under it and
you're cuz you stayed on the 180
okay now now you you take this you have
coming that's my opinion okay so follow
your rules is your here see this thing
rotating I'll explain it again my goal
is very small okay because as you go to
application Phase it's not cultivation
phase where you're trying to send him
you're looking for very
thing okay boom how much did his elbow
move from where it was I don't think so
watch again Bo boom here
camera just measure where's my Center
Line here's the hand you see what what
do you say engineer boy 3 4 in good okay
got it not half a foot here's the other
thing if you project away and you go to
grab that what about the foot rule okay
if he is stronger than me you're going
to pull yourself off balance or if he
knows he's stronger than me he'll just
pull me with that and I'm you see
okay so if you pay attention when you
have small small stuff this hand is here
my elbow is in that vertical plane which
is where we operate elbow power not hand
power elbow power so he pulls my hand
the elbows anchor on the same vertical
plane you see and now I can use this
foot to
shift okay so I'm going to shift oh and
theack
up I came in
whatever
boom boom
yeah I'll go slow and
smooth okay
try use the head go back go back
get a good tie on
him get it in the crook get the neck in
the
[Music]
crook more
seamless that's a long pause that's not
going to have he's going to do his
attack keep moving around the circle
[Music]
H so pass the adhesion it's like a k
hole where I pass the hand wrist control
up to the upper arm this one is going
from the arm hand to the inner arm past
the adhesion okay try it
again here and then it
goes hand go right up watch your watch
your arm
drag okay and then
Sean I'm not pulling them
back
the is a different part of the arm and
it's pushing down okay it's pushing
[Music]
down you guys see that not using my hand
and I'm not
ping his Bo all
right down without my palm okay you're
trying to break his head on the street
okay
[Music]
go here and then go
this hand go right up watch your watch
your arm
Dr okay and then
Sean I'm not pulling them
back the is a different part of the arm
and it's pushing down okay it's pushing
down
[Music]
you guys see that not using my hand and
I'm
not ping his back all
[Music]
right down without my palm okay you're
trying to break his head on the street
okay go
so this be here okay so I go here boom
and it's going to do the spiral that is
in net but what's the problem
here you're pushing yeah okay
so what I do instead is I'm going to go
around just take his inertial line it's
going that way you see that and I'm
going to go around
it and keep going around it so I'm not
contesting
it so his energy is going in right so if
you notice when we go
slow I always shove him in when we go
fast I don't shove you in okay there's
the energy is doing what it's doing so
we'll have him keep walking as he keeps
walking I'm doing
this okay we go
back right here I keep that there don't
smell it okay he keeps walk walk a
little slower please just a little
slower okay got it m my hand is doing
this my hand is doing this it's not
going
out I'm not making it go out
okay okay try it again